One of the most important principles for choosing a lover sensibly...
...is not to feel in any hurry to make a choice.
Being satisfied with being single is a precondition of satisfactory coupledom.
We cannot choose wisely when remaining single feels unbearable.
We have to be utterly at peace with the prospect of many years of solitude...
...in order to have any chance of forming a good relationship...
...or we'll love no longer being single...
...rather more than we love the partner who spared us being so.
Unfortunately, after a certain age, society makes singlehood feel dangerously unpleasant.
Communal life starts to wither.
People in couples are too threatened by the independence of the single...
...to invite them around very often...
...in case they are reminded of something they might have missed.
Friendship and sex are, despite all the gadgets, still remarkably hard to come by.
No wonder if when someone slightly decent, but not quite so, comes along,...
...we cling to them, to our eventual enormous cost.